Okay, this is going to be a full
overview of the exact trading strategy
that I've been using for the past year
and this is the strategy that has helped
me to generate over 1.2 million dollars
in payouts in the last 12 months.
So, the way this video is going to go,
first I'll show you proof that I
actually did do that many payouts. Then
I'll go for what I look for, key things
to know, fair pricing theory, which is
basically what is why the strategy
works.
And then I have just this past week of
trades, so I'll just go through the
trades I took this week and then
hopefully you can see a little bit about
it in action and then be able to
replicate it yourself. So,
this is the step-by-step trading
strategy that made me 1.2 million
dollars in payouts in the last 12 months
trading on prop firms. So, first a
little bit of proof. This is taken from
my Mac.
I have it in my Discord server actually.
Pretty much just Topstep payouts, so you
can you can pause, look through them if
you want, but
yeah, this is Wise. That's where Topstep
pays out. Eight Futures, really good
firm to use, 172k in payouts there.
Alpha Futures, I'm on the live account
now. I haven't sent live in like 2
months, but was at like 75k or
something.
Um there's a bit more. Lucid, I'm on
live as well.
Uh 75k payouts on Lucid in like a month
or 2 months.
Trade F7, 100k payouts or so.
I'm on live there as well. Apex, about
60k in payouts. They did ban me. Um I
wasn't given a reason. Funded Next, 67k
payouts.
Um another Topstep picture, I guess.
Uh but most importantly,
uh 1099 tax form. You can't fake this
stuff. Topstep paid me 250k last year
and then RiseWorks paid me 450k.
Uh and then the other firms send their
own 1099s cuz they just paid my bank
accounts.
Uh how much did I spend on evals? About
200 to 250k. I don't know the exact
amount, but it's under education
business services.
Um this was January, so
yeah, so I didn't really sell anything
at this point. It was just all prop
firms. So, Apex, Lucid, Topstep,
RiseWorks,
E8,
stuff like that. So,
unfortunately, I was 14k off a million
in my first year. Uh I started in March.
Um March, I think February or March
actually. So,
I didn't really get 12 full months to do
it, so that's why I didn't hit a
million. Very unfortunate.
But yeah, hopefully I'm going to hit
that this year.
So, hopefully you believe that I am who
I say I am. I'm who I say I am. I've
documented two full months of 100k
payouts on my Instagram, so if you want
to see like what firms I'm getting my
payouts from, then you could take a look
that as well.
Now, for the strategy, the most
important part.
I trade high time frame mean reversion,
low time frame continuation. So,
what I'm looking for is the New York
session open. It's like the main session
obviously to to trade for
me. Um continuation. I only trade it in
the first 5 to 10 minutes or I guess
like 0 to 10 minutes. Like I'm looking
for my first trade pretty much
instantly. After 10 minutes, I'm I'm
going to look for mean reversion
assuming there's been a move away from
the opening price. Mean reversion then
obviously is from 10 minutes to 90
minutes because continuation is the
first 10, mean reversion is just after
that.
Three to four trades max. You don't want
to over risk into a situation that's not
playing out in your favor. If you're
winning, then you can keep trading
obviously. If you're losing, it's not
the best to continue because that
usually means your bias isn't playing
out and then you should stop.
Um for the entry, I look for a
displacement
or a break of structure and a close just
depending on the volume and what session
I'm trading.
And
basically,
the way to be profitable on prop firms
is to have a bias that you're right a
majority of the time plus very, very
good risk management
as well as a precise entry. So,
the bias that I have is from high time
frame reversion and low time frame
continuation. I'll go into that in the
trade recaps, but
that's how I form my bias.
And always, that's usually going to be
the fair price at open. So,
a few key things to know. This prop firm
This strategy only works on prop firms.
If you were to trade it on a live
account, it would probably break even,
maybe win a little bit, but the reason
why I don't trade on live is that the
risk is so large just to make
basically like the most edge you can
have probably is like 1 to 5%. So, you'd
be risking tens of thousands of dollars
just to get 5% of tens of thousands of
dollars, which is definitely not worth
it when you could be trading a prop firm
with pretty much the same amount of
capital and basically no risk, just the
eval fee.
Risk management is definitely the most
important part
for trading in general.
Um it's just
you're not going to be you're not going
to be profitable unless you have very
specific, strict risk management.
Uh and the way that works for me is I'm
trading a different prop firm account
based on what I'm seeing in the market.
And uh I think it's a very unique
approach. Not Not not that many people
that I know actually take this approach.
So, what I'm doing is what I see in the
market is a specific amount of points
that I can target. Uh usually in the
direction of the session open. So, some
days I'll see 50 points on a reversion,
some days I'll see 20.
Based on that, you should trade a
different prop firm because each prop
firm you should be using a different
risk on.
And again, that's because risk
management is the most important thing.
Second, that's just because prop firms
have different rules. So,
if you want to optimize your profit on
prop firms, then you need to optimize
your risk management and trade a
different account based on what you see
in the market.
Um also going to go over A A+ A and B
setups, just pretty much like your bias.
You need both biases to line up, high
time frame reversion and low time frame
continuation to make an A+.
And then displacement plus break of
structure. Break of structure and a
close is an A+ setup. It's a lot more
likely to win when that happens.
Um I am trading pretty much every
displacement I see just because there's
a slight bit of edge that I want to
capture every single day in the market.
So, displacement is usually an A and
then B is when your biases are
like
going the opposite way. So, you
definitely don't want to trade you don't
want to trade the B+ setups, the B
setups.
Uh how to trade news days.
Um I will
Okay, I'll add a little thing here about
how I trade on news when I'm done with
these trade recaps. Uh it's pretty much
the exact same thing though, thankfully.
How to scale. Now, scaling is very
different on prop firm versus live. Like
on live, you're tracking your metrics,
you're slowly increasing your risk. Prop
firms, you need to take a different
approach. The reason for that is risk of
ruin.
If you have an edge in the market like I
do with the strategy, you don't want to
bust, which basically just means lose
all of your money and then not be able
to continue trading to capture your
edge. So,
in in terms of scaling, copy trading is
very complicated.
Y- you want to have
the exact pass rate. Like you want to
know your exact pass rate, your exact
payout chance, your average payout. All
of that, you need to know these exact
statistics before you start copy trading
just so you can confirm that your chance
of losing everything is less than 5%. If
it's more than 5%, then you don't want
to do it. If you don't know, then you
definitely don't want to copy trade.
Obviously, if you have Okay, well, I'll
just tell you like if you have more than
$10,000, it's fine to start copy
trading, but most people do not. So, I
would recommend stay away from copy
trading.
Uh it is just going to ruin your your
bankroll. Your risk of losing everything
is way higher, so
start with one account,
get payouts from there on, and then you
can invest those and then start copy
trading.
>> [snorts]
>> But the way I scale is
I couldn't copy trade at first.
Um just cuz I guess I didn't have enough
money or I didn't feel comfortable doing
it. What you should do is find a
strategy like mine or you could use your
own, but find a strategy that works
multiple times per day. So, you're able
to trade multiple times per day.
And the reason for that is you want to
trade each account once per day
instead of copy trading all of them
once. So, if you have five accounts, you
want to trade five different setups per
day ideally. Now, I know most most day
trading strategies only work like once a
day.
That's true, I I guess, but the way that
I created the strategy was so that it
worked five times a day.
Uh it works on every single session
open. So,
>> [snorts]
>> that would be any EST, the 6:00 p.m.
when the market reopens, 8:00 p.m. Asian
session, 3:00 a.m. London session,
uh 8:30 a.m. when there's news, 9:30
a.m.
Eastern, and then 2:00 p.m. Eastern for
the New York PM session.
I'll go into that in the fair pricing
theory like in literally like 1 minute,
but that is how I just trade every
single session because I have 40
accounts, I'm copy trading five at once,
and I want to get maximum exposure to
the edge before it dies.
Now, why does it work? This is obviously
fair pricing theory.
It is what I studied in college. I
graduated with a degree in quantitative
finance, and so that is what I've been
applying to trading on prop firms, risk
management, strategy generation, that
sort of stuff.
Basically, a brief overview of fair
pricing theory is the New York session
open acts as the first major intraday
reference point for fair auction.
Early moves away from that price are
often driven by opening flow, liquidity
imbalances, stops, hedging, momentum,
participation, not necessarily by a
true, long-lasting repricing of the
index.
So, what I mean by this is we need to
actually be aware of what we're trading.
We're trading Nasdaq futures. And on
Nasdaq, Nasdaq's made up of 100
companies, right? So, we're trading
actual, valuable companies. We're not
trading
something like Bitcoin where the value
is unknown. The value is determined by
an auction place of people agreeing
what's a what's a fair price for
Bitcoin. We're trading actual companies
that have an actual fair price. That's
in the long term. Now, in the short term
and why I think we can have an edge
trading this sort of market is
um on the very short term, there is a
little bit of not liquidity. I don't
really believe liquidity is a very
important part of Nasdaq just because
it's so liquid.
But but basically, there's some sort of
auction marketplace
theory at play in the short term just
because a bunch of people
gain access to market at the same time.
Like 9:30 open, all the overnight orders
come in, all the banks start doing their
trading then, stuff like that. So, I
believe that the fair price would stay
the same
even when the the price on the chart is
like moving up or moving down from that
just because of the introduction of new
market participants, opening flow,
liquidity imbalances, stopped hedging,
momentum participation, that sort of
stuff. So,
basically, I believe the 9:30 a.m. is
the fair price. Any move away from that
is unfair. So, I would trade a reversion
back to the opening price.
And that is the high time frame
reversion. Usually, it's it's more of a
medium time frame reversion, I guess.
And then I just use a continuation for
my entry. And the fair price is at open.
So,
let's just take a look at this week. I'm
recording this on the 28th, Saturday.
So, yeah, this would be Friday.
Let me just zoom in here.
9:30 a.m. EST, we are getting the
opening candle right here. It's this red
one.
So,
what I believe is the price before is
the fair price.
And just because the market has opened
and all these new participants have
gained access and they're treating it
now like a peer-to-peer auction,
does not mean the inherent value of
Nasdaq should have changed. So, what I
do is first I trade a continuation away
from this price just because the group
of overnight orders that come in are
usually set in one direction like this
case is obviously red because the
majority of the orders are crossing the
spread in the down direction. So, I like
to trade a continuation of that move
just because usually displacement
continues more often than it does not.
So, in that sense, you can gain a little
bit of edge just by trading a
continuation of that move. And then
after that, I definitely love to trade
mean reversion back towards the opening
price.
So, I'm not going to cherry-pick any
examples. I'm just going to go through
this exact week and tell you exactly
what trades I took and why. So, the
first trade, continuation. The only way
you want to look for a continuation is
short because the first candle was red,
which means the overnight orders were
mostly short. So, you're going to look
for shorts. And in terms of an entry,
like I said over here,
break of structure and close or
displacement. Displacement candle
usually, at least in my opinion the way
I trade it, is a candle that's larger
than the previous one and it doesn't
really have any wicks. So, this would be
a displacement candle since it's larger
than the previous one and it has no
wicks, basically. This one would not cuz
it has lots of wicks. This one, no.
This one, kind of, like 50/50. Yes, no,
yes, that sort of thing. But yeah, break
of structure. So, it broke this
structure right here.
The opening sort of wicked this
structure, so I didn't like it. If the
opening candle closed here, I would have
shorted. But the reason I took this
candle is because it broke this
structure and it closed below. So, I was
predicting on a displacement away from
the opening price. And just for all
these trades, I'm just going to be using
a 1 to 1.5 risk to reward. It's a very
common one. I think most people should
be using that. I'm not sure if you are,
but at least on your evaluation, you
should be using it. The reason for that
is most evaluations are plus 3,000
before they're minus 2,000. And
essentially, that's three to two, which
is 1.5 risk to reward. So, like your
entire challenge when you have three up
here and two down here, that's the exact
same as a 1 to 1.5 risk to reward. So,
you can sort of just like
compact the entire challenge into a 1 to
1.5 and just keep on trading that. It's
just I don't know what I've done to
simplify it.
But yeah, so that I'm just going to have
all of them be 38 points TP, 25 points
stop loss, and then you can choose your
contract sizing based on your risk
aversion.
Now, obviously, break of structure and
it closes below there. So, first short,
continuation of this move. Next, mean
reversion. There is not any structure to
close above. There's kind of this one
right here, but there's not any
structure to close above like there is
here. Obviously, this is a really
important piece of structure, which
basically just means like it's lower
than these two points.
So, you can easily get a close below.
There's no structure here to close
below, so you can enter on a
displacement. This is like very
obviously displacement candle. There's
no wick down here. This wick is very
small compared to the candle. And this
candle is bigger than this entire
previous candle. So, right when this one
closes up here,
I'm trading a mean reversion back in the
direction of the opening price.
What I was saying earlier about fair
price at open and trading a different
account based on what you see,
technically, you would have edge all the
way from here, this close, up to the
opening candle here. So, yeah, it does
come up here, it taps the opening
candle, then it continues its shorts.
So,
in that sense,
you would
For your take profit, either you could
just stick with consistent 1 to 1.5 like
I do, or you can move this take profit
up to all the way up here. That would be
fine as well if you want to capture more
points on a funded account or something
like that.
I have very different specific risk
management approach, so honestly, it's
whatever works best for you.
And then changing your account based on
what you're seeing in the market is sort
of what I do sometimes.
Um
Like if I was to enter if this dropped
all the way down here and I was able to
take longs here, I'd have a lot more
points in favor of the opening price.
So, I would trade an account that I need
more points on if that makes sense, just
based on my risk management.
So, yeah, that was the first entry,
displacement, closed above this one,
pretty standard. Next, I usually don't
look for shorts this late, but this is
like the most perfect short setup just
because you can see previous structures
right here.
Incredible displacement down, closed
right below the structure. Like at this
point, I was so confident it was going
to come down here to this low. And 38
points is pretty much exactly to this
low, so there's like literally no reason
not to take it.
I know it does deviate away from the
time, so I guess it could go from an A+
down to an A setup, but I mean, it was
just perfect setup. You get
displacement, you get close below,
everything. Everything needed for
continuation shorts.
Next, I was going to look for more mean
reversion. In this case,
pretty much the same thing.
There were lots of wicks here, so none
of these are displacement candles except
for this one, but it's not really that
large compared to this one previous and
it didn't close consistently above it.
Like see this one closed way above this
one, so it's like a real displacement in
that sense. This one, not really.
So, I was waiting for a close above this
this this box of absolutely choppiness.
So, finally, we get the volume spike, we
get a close above this box right here,
and then I just longed. Um
I guess it just speaks for itself, I
hope. Just long because it closed above,
mean reversion in this
middle medium time frame, I guess,
reversion. Also, I usually stop looking
for trades at 11:00 or just whenever the
volume dies out.
Next,
well, this is actually a very good day.
I think I posted this one on Instagram,
but this was four wins, so
um
and nothing cherry-picked. So, this was
literally just my past week of trading.
I should mostly be on Instagram, but
okay.
3:26, this was Thursday. Now,
basically, first thing you can do is you
can mark out the candle pre-open, which
we believe is the fair price. Any move
away from that is unfair. So, this
initial displacement is a really good
candle to short on. It is an unfair
move, so you are predicting a
continuation of the unfair move, which
is fine.
That's that's just why you don't want to
look for continuations too far after the
open.
So,
yeah, first trade, it closed below just
like it did in just like it did on this
day. It closed below this structure,
this structure, all of that. Just closed
below, short 25, 38 take profit. You can
also backtest just double-check.
Hmm, almost stopped me out, but it was a
it was a win. You can go back and check
if you want.
So, yeah, this is a win.
And then after that, so I'm going to
look for a mean reversion. So,
basically, longs coming back to this
price here. Um
So, the first candle, there is no real
displacement here because the wick is
humongous. Same here. This is a decent
displacement candle.
So, I guess I could have entered here if
I wanted to. The reason I didn't is just
because I thought this structure here
was going to be really key.
And
if we were to close by the structure, I
was pretty confident we'd come back to
at least the top of this opening candle
here. And then from there, I just had a
little bit more of take profit. So, uh
you can just let it run. Essentially,
it's pretty much random, at least in my
opinion, once it gets back to the
opening price. It's pretty much random
from there. So, I was pretty confident
at a 1 to 1 when it got back to here and
then just letting it run for the rest.
And the reason for this entry was break
of structure, close above.
Um
And it's sort of a continuation trade.
That's what That's I think that's what I
mean when I say high time frame
reversion, low time frame continuation.
High time frame reversion,
even though it's like 5 minutes, I guess
I mean
medium time frame because we're coming
back to the opening price. So, by
reversion, I just mean coming back to
the opening price. And by continuation,
I just mean
like this this series of green candles
or the series of gray candles for this
continuation.
This one's not the best example. This
one's a little bit better, but yeah,
continuation, I guess, kind of.
That's just the words I use to describe
it. Then from there, I believe this move
up was unfair, so I was going to trade
another reversion back to the opening
price, which you can see it perfectly
came back into. There's no structure,
really. There is a bit bit of structure
here. The problem is if it was to close
below here, which it did, this would be
a
not the best short. It'd be like a an A
to B+ setup just because you're already
at the fair price, which I believe was
to be in this rectangle somewhere.
You're already here. So, essentially,
from here, it's random. There is a
little bit of momentum continuation, but
you don't want to rely on just that
alone. My favorite thing ever is to mean
revert back to the session open. So,
you're already at the session open, so
there's no point in reverting anywhere,
basically. From here though,
very good trade to revert to the session
open. This is a displacement candle, so
this is where I can enter off a
displacement.
It is the first displacement that occurs
because this one, too big of wick. This
one,
a little bit too big of wick.
Kind of the same size as and it's
definitely smaller than this candle
here. Kind of the same size as this one
and it's like right on the opening
price. This one, wick. This one's
finally displacement, bigger than this
one. Basically, no wicks, consistent
close below here. So,
very good entry there as well. So,
that's how we enter off displacement.
This is another three for three day.
That's the wrong tool.
Okay.
Three for three.
So, honestly, like I barely
ever did not lose on these days.
I did lose these days, so you're about
to see you're about to see what a losing
trade looks like.
Okay, first example.
Opening candle, this is on Wednesday.
Opening candle right here, I just marked
that out. And you can see it sort of
plays around the candle.
Like the opening candle here would be
all the way over here. It just comes up,
taps that. It sort of plays around the
fair price, and that's why that's just
what I've noticed over like just look at
this candle like the wick there, boom.
Wick there, boom. It sort of chops
around it here for a bit before dumping.
Just makes me think that the opening
candle actually has something to do with
the the fair price of NQ. And again,
just what I said earlier about why it
works is the influx of participants
creates an unfair move away. So,
yeah, lots of action around the opening
price like
throughout the the period. I got a
little bit more into fair price in my
one-on-one. So, if you're interested in
that, link will be in the description. I
also go over like the exact risk
management approach you should take, how
many accounts to buy, which firms to
use, how much to risk per trade in terms
of dollars, points, all that sort of
stuff, how to risk on different firms,
copy trading, scaling, all that stuff.
But yeah, I mean it it sort of can If I
could extend this rectangle here, this
is just picture, but if I could, then it
sort of chops around here, which may
again makes me believe this is a very
fair price.
Uh and
one thing I forgot to say,
news does change fair price because news
changes the inherent value of Nasdaq
futures, at least in my opinion. I mean,
I could be totally wrong or I could be
right, but I mean, again, I've done like
a good amount of payouts, and it's been
very consistent, so I believe it I
believe it's true.
News changes fair price, but opening
session does not. So, you do have to be
careful if some sort of news comes out
and changes fair price. Obviously, like
you look at this past week, there's been
a lot of news with the war, tweets,
stuff like that.
That's more related to fair pricing
theory. I do a lot more of that
one-on-one, so it's like too complicated
to explain here, and there's not really
any point. I'm just just explaining the
the very basic strategy that I use. So,
Wednesday, mark out the opening candle,
displacement up, close above here, very
good for a long.
Just continuation. I think that's pretty
standard.
And then next, I wanted to take a short.
Good displacement candle here. We're
getting 38 points or so back to the
opening price here, so very standard
short as well. This one did lose.
That is totally okay. Losing is very
very common. It's part of trading, as
you should know. You need to take your
losses better than you take your wins,
just because the inherent value of
losing or the the emotional value of
losing is two times as much as the
absolute value of winning. So, you need
to learn to handle your losses better
than you handle your wins.
And then for your short, another short
would be fine because we're coming back
to the opening price. This one closed
below here.
And it's a displacement, everything A+
setup, like 100% going to win this
trade. Maybe not 100, maybe like 70 to
80, but that's really good cuz it's 1 to
1.5, so
Yeah, that was why I shorted here and
here. Just displacement.
This is an A setup. I love the break and
close below. It's an A+.
But yeah, I mean, I'm going to I'm just
going to enter every A setup I see. Some
B+ I'll enter.
Just cuz, you know, I'm trying to trade
all my accounts.
Next,
it displaced all the way down through
the fair price.
So, the reason I didn't take
continuation shorts or anything here is
because the opening candle right here
was very green, so I wanted longs to
start. And then after this initial
displacement up, sort of just trade
reversion because the initial unfair
move is sort of over.
But yeah, so
that's why I didn't take shorts here.
Next, I'm definitely trading a mean
reversion back to here.
In this example, this was off a
displacement candle, so again, not the
best entry, and but that's fine. I mean,
you have some points in your favor
coming back to a reversion.
Displacement again, it closed above the
previous one. Barely any wick. I would
prefer the body to be a little bit
larger, but I mean, I'm still just going
to enter on this.
And it's larger than the previous one,
so just long here.
And something like this. This one did
get stopped out. Usually, if I get
stopped out, it's due to a displacement
down, which is unfair, and then I can
just reenter instantly, which is what
happened here and is what happened here.
Displacement candle close.
Definitely not the best entry, for sure.
I mean, I would have probably preferred
this candle right here, actually.
But yeah, I didn't want to miss out on
it. And this candle was like very large
in volume, but I definitely should have
entered here. It's pretty much the same.
This one's a lot
more
sure to win just because it closed
almost above this.
I don't like the wick, though, so not
not the best action here.
Probably could have been better to
actually just not trade not take this
trade at all, but
win, loss, win,
loss, win. So, three and two, so
that would be three out of five on this
day.
Two more days, and then and then we'll
be done. So, I know it's been a long
video, but hopefully you are
understanding this, and hopefully you
can implement it yourself.
I will mention Let me just mention
news, how to backtest.
Okay, so I'll go over these things as
soon as I get through these next two
days.
Okay, Tuesday.
Not the best day, unfortunately, but
that's fine. First candle, we mark out
the pre-opening candle right here. We
believe that's the fair price, so it it
chops around here forever, so I mean,
probably is the fair price.
Okay, so on longs, I wanted it closed
above this structure. I really wish this
candle here, which is the opening
candle, I really wish it didn't have
these large wicks. I wish it just opened
here and then closed here. That'd be a
perfect long. The problem was it didn't,
so I had to long all the way up here.
Not my favorite to long at the all-time
high of the last 30 minutes, but I mean,
it's fine.
I [clears throat] truly believed it was
just going to go up from there based on
the strategy, and I always follow the
strategy. So, it's a fine entry.
Unfortunately, it doesn't play out.
You could take
Honestly, I have no idea why I did not
take this, but looking at it now, this
is a displacement candle.
And this closed below here, so you could
take a mean reversion short here.
I guess there might not have been enough
points in my favor to take this trade.
Or I might have taken it and just not
marked it out, but
that would have been a pretty standard
trade as well, to be honest.
Okay, and then it displaces So, yeah, it
chops around here for a bit, confirming
that this is probably the fair price,
and then this displacement here, I
believe is unfair. So, displacement
candle up, close above here. It's
displacements again, since the body is
larger than this one, there's no wicks.
Send another one long back to the
opening price for the reversion.
This one stopped out.
Second attempt, another displacement,
close above here.
This one won, so two losses and one win.
Not the best day, but
it's all part of the broad process, so
just getting in as as much reps as
possible. Monday was a very weird day.
I have just I just have the 5-minute
chart here. I'm always on the 1-minute.
But Monday was a very weird day. The
reason for that is the wicks were so
bad. Like the open Let me find an
example. The open literally looked like
this. If you go back and look at Monday,
you'll see what I mean. The open looked
like this. So, there was literally
nothing at all.
Monday is like usually the least
volatile day, I think, or it could be
Friday, just cuz there's no news in the
morning. But yeah, Monday was absolutely
no volume, so I literally took one
trade. It was the shortest trade ever.
And what I did on this trade is usually
when there's no volume or if I'm on a
different session where there's no
volume, like Asian session or New York
p.m., I'll go to the 5-minute, and I'll
trade the exact same strategy. So,
yeah, as you can see the open, this was
the opening candle right here.
Like the wicks were were very very large
and compared to the body, meaning it
sort of chopped around in here, and then
wick,
wick, so pretty much nothing to trade.
But yeah, so 5-minute, I take the exact
same approach. I'll wait for a break and
a close below previous structure.
And I'll look for high timeframe
reversion, low timeframe continuation.
So, the open was here, so this is the
fair price.
We are getting a high timeframe
reversion because it's gone up, and
we're getting a low timeframe
continuation because it's gone down
recently.
And in terms of the entry,
I wanted a break of this structure. It's
pretty much the only structure. This is
kind of
not the best. These are like equal.
But I mean, this this candle would break
this one just like it breaks this one,
but there's no structure here.
No structure here.
So, you want a break and a close below
structure. So, this is where you get the
break,
the close on 5-minute. You break, close,
low timeframe continuation, high
timeframe reversion. So, you're getting
all four of those.
And then yeah,
you're also getting points in your favor
back to the open. So, everything lined
up, so I just took one trade today, and
it was
just this short, I believe, so
Honestly, pretty easy if you don't see
any volume, so that would work as well.
We're 28 minutes in, so hopefully I'll
wrap this up really quickly with news
and how to backtest.
News, let me check if there's any news
this week I can go over.
What exactly I traded.
Okay, so news, I'm always talking about
8:30 news.
There's some little niche things like
you don't want to be in a trade when
9:45 or 10:00 a.m. news comes out, but
that's like kind of niche. But
red folder news 8:30 is what I'm mainly
referring to.
So, let me just look at
Thursday 8:30 and how to trade news.
Yeah, this is the open. News. Okay, so
on on news days, what we believe is that
the This is Wednesday.
We believe I believe that the fair price
is the candle before news. And just
because news came out, news is already
priced in on average. Everyone knows the
desired Not desired. Everyone knows the
average outcome of news,
just because of insiders, there's quant
funds,
Polymarket as well, like telling you
what the average news is going to be.
Like the average price of news is
already priced in. And usually like
>> [clears throat]
>> the overnight is usually trying to price
in news, at least in my opinion. So,
when news comes out, the volume spike
off news is so unfair. That's literally
just funds taking advantage of
uninformed retail traders,
kind not hunting their stop losses, but
just taking advantage of uninformed
participants in the market. I don't
believe stop losses are truly hunted.
That's not really a thing.
But yeah, just taking advantage of
uninformed participants. So,
I I'll do is I always mark out the
candle before news. So this will be the
29 candle.
Um
and then from there any move away from
that is unfair. So I'll go
low time frame continuation, high time
frame reversion, close above break of
structure, and points in your favor. So
let's see if we can get all five of
those things in our favor.
First, we are going to obviously we're
going long because it dropped off. So
that's the first one.
Second,
we are getting this continuation trend
of green. Good. Now we just need a break
a close above and like
points in our favor.
Which points in our favor means don't
long here because you're in the fair
price.
Uh so we'll look for a structure which
happens to be here
and here. This one, all right, there we
go. It closed above
as expected. We're getting points in our
favor, 32 or so.
Uh I'll just set it to 38.25 is just the
average what I do.
1:1.5, 1.5. There you go.
So
reversion back to the fair price
pre-news. This this works on every news.
You can go back and look. Um back test
it.
And yeah, it's a close above.
Low time frame continuation, high time
frame like zero medium time frame
reversion I guess is what I mean by
that. But yeah, pretty standard news
entry there.
So that's how you trade news and then
how to back test. Back testing is
very important. Um
the way I would recommend you back test
is
most people back test and all they care
about is their equity curve. So they
will think
okay, this is a profitable strategy
because on average I've made money.
That's true if you were in the live
market. Now prop firms have a very
specific set of rules though where a
live strategy that makes money would not
work on prop firms because of their
specific rules. So everyone who's back
testing and saying, yeah, I made money
on this live. I'm going to trade on the
prop firm. That's not going to work most
of the time. Some of the times it will
work
if you're on a funded account and you're
in a high amount of profit. At that
point like if you're up 10k on a funded
account then it would work because
you're making money on a $10,000
balance. Funded accounts have drawdown,
consistency rules, payout rules, winning
day rules, all that sort of stuff. And
you see this drop off here where that
wouldn't kill you in a live account, it
would kill you in a prop firm account.
So you're not able to realize this full
expected value of this linear uptrend
essentially in a prop firm account. So
what you should do on a prop firm
challenge
is
let me extend this down here. Let me
mark this as 48.
This is going to be for 50k, 53. What
you should do when you're back testing
is do this sort of thing. Start here.
One trade per day. Just one trade per
day. So instead of your equity curve
looking something like this,
your equity curve is going to look
something like this.
I guess it'll be something it'll be more
like this.
Assuming you won. It'll look like this
because you finished the day with a win.
If it I hope that makes sense.
Uh you finish the day with a win or if
you were to lose, you finish the day
with a loss. So you don't have a curve.
You just have a a teleport. It sort of
just teleports like you win or you lose
because of how the drawdown works.
So
I want you to back test like this. Take
one trade per day. Say you go for a
thousand. You win a thousand. Now you're
right here.
So it looked like this because you ended
the day up a thousand. Now this is no
longer your drawdown. Now your drawdown
is 49,000 because the way end of day
trailing drawdown works.
From here, say you risk another
thousand, you come back to here
and then you lose again.
That would [clears throat] mean
you lose the eval, right? Obviously cuz
you hit 49.
So I want you to back test and find your
pass rate. You need to pretend that
you're trading a prop firm challenge.
You don't want to pretend that you're
trading a live account because you're
not. You're trading a prop firm. So you
need to take this exact approach to back
testing. You do not want to do this ever
unless you're in a live account. You
want to trade like this. You want to
back test like this because you're
trading a prop firm account. So you need
to find your exact pass rate. You need
to make sure your drawdown trails. So if
you win, you bring your drawdown up to
49. If you win again, you hit 52, you
bring your drawdown up to 50. Drawdown
stops trailing at 50.
So you need to find out how often you're
going to pass the prop firm challenge.
And then
based on that, if it's $100 for the prop
firm and you're passing 33% of them,
meaning you're hitting 53 before the
trailing drawdown,
uh
33% of the time you win,
then this would be $300.
You can find out your average cost to
achieve the funded account based on
this. So the cost, your pass rate, which
you can back test,
divide it and then you get the average
cost of a funded account.
From that, you can know if you're
profitable based on more statistics like
your average payout and your payout
chance.
Um but yeah, this is how you should back
test. Please do not back test like it's
a live account. A whole group of
strategies that do not work on live will
work on prop firms. Strategies that work
on prop firms do not work on live. This
is a prop firm specific strategy. If you
back test it on live, I assume it's
going to break even. I haven't even done
it. Like there's literally no point for
me to back test this thing on live
because I only trade prop firms. I only
need to optimize it for the pass rate. I
only need to optimize it for the average
payout times the expected payout. So I
hope that makes sense. I hope you go
back, back test, pretend you have 10
prop firm accounts. See how many of them
you can pass using your strategy, if you
want, using this strategy, if you want.
But yeah, please just use
prop firm back testing, okay?
You need to find your pass rate. You do
not need your average profit, your sharp
ratio, your
expected profit per trade, your win
rate. That does not matter. The only
thing that matters is this.
So hopefully that made sense.
And I will as well have a one-on-one
mentorship link in the description of
this video if you're interested in
learning more from me specifically about
how I trade prop firms.